Jennifer's in Georgia hi Jennifer how
are you I'm good how are you doing
better than I deserve
what's up so my question is I have some
credit-card debt and I have a car car
payment and I just sold a car paid off
the loan and I have some cash extra and
I do need to buy something else so this
is all to pay off my debt that's why I
sold a car and so my question is given
that I have that I have about twenty
four thousand dollars in credit card
debt and I'm using a budget and I'm
using the unset tool I just you're
looking for a suggestion of how much do
I pay for a used car and there's
something that's going to get me around
that's reliable and so I just use the
money icon you there I think we may have
lost you okay all right let's uh she's
there she's I think she's there let's
try again
are you there Jennifer okay there you
are okay okay I think we a little
technical glitch okay so okay one more
time one more time you are in debt I
have credit
I'm not credit card debt I have about
was around up to 25,000 I had a car
payment I just sold my car I sold it for
about 16 thousand I paid off the loan
and I have about sixty seven hundred
cash from it by a car and seventy seven
hundred sixty seven hundred yeah I know
you need a thousand dollars left over
for your maybe step on okay okay um so
you think I should just use that I don't
know if I should even we've got to get
something even cheaper I don't want to
but you're fine well you can always sell
a car cars aren't that big a deal I mean
five thousand dollar car sure aren't
that big a deal so you're not gonna be
driving this car that long because
you're going to get out of debt and then
you're going to move up in car and so
you know yeah just buy five thousand
dollar car or four thousand dollar car
or whatever and then let's get in attack
mode and that that if you're careful
with what you buy
and you're not trying to buy something
that you worry about how it looks but
instead how it runs you can get a lot of
car for five grand okay you can get a
great old Camry or a great ol Ford
Taurus or Cavalier or something like
that these are just a little land yachts
right maybe an old Honda Accord that
kind of a thing and something and have a
mechanic check it are you single
yes you got someone that can look at a
car with you are you a car expert I'm
pretty good with cars I can have my dad
come look at it with me or take it to a
mechanic yeah either one I mean spend 20
30 bucks and have a basic one over with
a mechanic on it you don't need to spend
200 but just make sure that you're
getting something and what we're looking
for here is not sex appeal we're looking
for reliability great because this is
just your get out of debt car it's not
it's not it's not it's not who you are
you're not that car you're you're a
better car later you're not a Honda
Civic Jennifer girl that I had a really
cute kind of a dream car that I just
sold so yeah I have to remember that
it's not in a car they're fine then you
can become good I've got I've got nice
cars now but I drove crap for a while to
get myself out of debt and now I Drive
whatever I wanna drive and so you pay it
you live like no one else you drive like
no one else so that later you drive like
no one else